[موسيقى]
ارض حباها الله بكثير من جمال الطبيعه
وتنوعها وابتلاها بين حين واخر بزلازل لم
تنسى الذاكره التركيه
الله اكبر
في هذه المره جاء الزلزال عظيما في مداه
الجغرافي فقد ضرب عددا من المدن وثقيلا في
كلفته الانسانيه اذ تجاوز عداد الضحايا
الالف ومنذ ساعات الاولى للكارثه في تعداد
مرشح ليرتفع ويرتفع معه عدد الجرحى ستحتاج
تركيا الى كثير من الجهد والمال والوقت
لتستوعب المحنه الطبيعيه ومثله بل اكثر
منه على الارجح لتتجاوز اثارها الكارثيه
كارثه تعيد الى الاذان نسخا قديمه منها في
ذاكره لا تكتفي باستعاده العقود من
السنوات بل والقرون كذلك بالامس القريب
وبالضبط في شهر نوفمبر من عام 2020 ضرب
زلزال بقوه 6.6 ولايه ازمير التركيه مخلفا
بحسب اداره الكوارث التركيه ازيد من 120
وفيات قبل هذا الزلزال كان هناك اخر في
منطقه بحر ايجا ضرب مدينه بودروم في العام
2017 وقبل عام من ذلك ضرب زلزال اخر ولايه
وان بشده تجاوزت سبع درجات يقول اهل
الاختصاص ان تركيا ارض الزلازل بامتياز اذ
ان السجلات العلميه تثبت انها تتعرض ما
بين كل ست وسبع سنوات
لزلزال يمكن لدرجاته ان تتجاوز السبع
تتصدر منطقه بحر ايجه قائمه المناطق
المهدده بالزلازل فقد تعرضت في المئه عام
الماضي الى ما لا يقل عن 23 زلزالا مدمرا
واذا ما اوغلنا في التاريخ الطبيعي لتركيا
سنجده يحدثنا عما عرف بزلزال القيامه
الصغرى عام
1509 ذلك الذي ضرب بحر مرمره وتسبب في
دمار كبير لمدينه اسطنبول ولا يسعى ذلك
التاريخ تجاهل زلزال
1719 الذي ضرب نفس المدينه على نطاق شاسع
وقاس تماما كما فعل بها زلزلان اخران في
1766 و
عديده هي تلك المحطات المؤلمه بما تخلفه
من خسائر في الارواح والممتلكات الا ان
زلزالي جولجوك ودوجا اخذ في عام
1999 مكانه مفجعه في ذلك الاول جد في شهر
اغسطس وادى الى مقتل ما يزيد عن 17 الف
شخص اضافه الى قرابه 120 الف مصاب في حين
وقع الثاني في شهر نوفمبر والبلاد لم
تستفق بعد من صدمه ووطاه سابقه مخلفا
قرابه الف قتيل وقرابه 700 الف مصاب اما
الخسائر الماديه في هذا وذاك فحدث ولا حرج
تقول انقره انها خبرت مثل هذه الكوارث
واعدت لها وكاله متخصصه هي الان تكافح
لجعل فاتوره تلك الزلازل اقل فداحه بيد ان
الخروج من هذا النسق العالي لتواتر
الزلازل باخف الاضرار يحتاج ثوره عمرانيه
في بلاد تجمع بين المباهات بالمنجزات
الحديثه والحفاظ على ميراث مدن كثير منها
وجهه سياحيه جزء مهم من مبانيها يفتقد اخر
الصيحات الهندسيه في التعامل مع مفاجات
الارض كلما زلزلت زلزالها وانتبه العالم
ليقول مالها